yo here we go against sauerkraut yeah
Grandmaster slap coach it Chuck we
already had a ton of cool dudes and the
Kings Indian so let's try for a new one
we have what do we have four out of nine
as my score and no drawers hey no
drawers he wants to get in this be 5c 5d
5v5 but I think this is a situation
where i can just castle and let them
take c5 g5g five castles i think ism is
a actually common line relatively common
line so let's try to be quick about it
okay not sure if Quincy to us right down
but okay I start to think long here it
will reach your game so it should be
totally bad where am I going here I
think I think controlling if five should
be should be the right policy maybe I
can just like rook e1 route de bonheur
then possibly five in the right moment
okay Queen a 5mm that actually makes me
reconsider I mean he has to think about
me taking the pawn at some point and B
492 is certainly good for Wyatt at least
to some degree probably taking on c4 but
even then I'm not sure that the queen is
so well placed so Knight b6 okay i want
i want bishop to everyone that's a good
setup very sound and solid bowel really
cheeks I he takes with the bishop am
sorry i was just briefly thinking it
will take with the he wants to take with
them and with a pawn which is not
working at all and take special chinks
what you won something
they have no real alternative okay he
has five maybe maybe I should have
started with Bishop f4 actually before
he gets in d5 in the first place I was
better right that was a better move
simply Bishop f4 first getting in this
critical diagonal now we can go d 50 he
doesn't ok maybe you can still play it
later but i'm not sure i get may ever
get in b3 Bishop f4 I'm certainly in
good shape and then least I'm up on the
clock yachi jack is a well-known strong
blitz player and also in over the board
blitz ok what is this 95 takes rook
change
okay I just let's just push him back
here it cannot be bad at all 95 i'm
taking a six is hanging i cannot be bad
okay so take here and now i can take a
six but not sure ninety-five looks looks
like the right strategic move actually
just try to get the bishop pale I put
this rook on d5 yes the si si book to
you night-night beef is also there are
not just not just them Red deform now d
4 is not a problem really but not before
hmm
okay let's go back then so push up here
it's an important important detail that
I've have this really strong bishop
square this should actually compensate
that the night is on deform the bishop
is really strong they're looking at f7
and stuff like that yep should hear what
is he doing then we should be five maybe
maybe okay I can maybe try to soften up
his King side a little bit with h4 h5
might be an idea okay does he want to
double okay let's let's do this first
okay so Jack allows me to do that night
is checking on v3 so I always have that
also it's not such a big deal i hope how
do i might perform probably yes I see
but I don't have to take them I don't
have to take let's see move roop g6 is
what he wants to do after the capture 92
as a problem would like to play the rope
here I look everyone I mean this is what
I wanted to do not sure that I get it in
though haha ticking is kind of
uncomfortable
maybe just this move threatening
threatening on age six preparing Luke h3
look age three it still can check f4
Queen chicks kog does not it does not
have anything on the G file because of
my because of my c4 Bishop time morning
look drop g3 trying to do that g3 cannot
take unfortunately on age six here it's
not not ideal Queen f2 I just it's just
a check cannot trade queens here
don't see a real decisive idea
rook g3 is not leading to anywhere
really isn't but it seems relatively
best a queen of two teenage to taking
their planets put this here it's not
really not great but I don't I don't see
you in on when I mean no real way
forward maybe now I can she hear me he
just blended the maid wow I was a else
travels really tricky as usual he's the
games against him I always really tense
yeah I don't know I was thinking it
should be quite good for me but I didn't
didn't really find a decisive thing okay
this is what the combo suggesting
yeah Queen a sick song ji have to trade
i guess i didn't want that I mean even
if i'm slightly better i didn't want
that it's there but here's why could if
i could have chatted cheek and he'll
check cubits this Queen to f4 I don't
know some point at the end may be Queen
f4 yeah that's maybe true
yeah it's nothing in nothing great i
mean i can i can play something
something like that but this is only
giving him a decent game i mean i think
i think i'm still okay his night is
potentially better than mine and my
bishop here yeah okay very tricky i was
lucky that he run into the maid yeah
okay well thanks for watching